[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back investigators say the
murder of Georgia woman Debbie Collier
was deliberate and personal as officials
worked to determine who killed the 59
year old last month leaving her body
burned in the woods miles away from home
Collier was reported missing by her
family on September 10th a day later her
body was recovered naked in the woods
more than 50 miles from her home
authorities say her body appeared to
have been burned and that she was
gripping a small tree her cause of death
is still not determined but officials
are calling her death a homicide Collier
was captured on surveillance footage
purchasing several items at Family
Dollar prior to being found those items
including a tarp and a red tote bag were
reportedly found near her body the case
grew more mysterious after it was
revealed Collier sent her daughter
nearly two thousand four hundred dollars
through venmo just minutes after Collier
left the store it reportedly had a note
attached saying they are not going to
let me go though officials say there's
no indication Collier was abducted
Terry I know it's cliche but follow the
money it often works so does that two
thousand four hundred dollar Collier
Center daughter just before she went
missing seems strange and could it be
that she knew something was going to
happen
you know what Brian this entire case is
extremely strange you do have to follow
the money though I agree with you there
and if you follow the money you trace
Collier's last steps it really could be
that there was an abduction and there
was an attempt to extort her perhaps her
abductors wanted her to purchase the
materials to cover up her own body and
they didn't want those materials to be
traced back to them and if that's the
case then that's psychological Terror
and maybe they wanted the money to come
from the daughter and the mother was
trying to get the daughter the money the
prosecution is going to have to put this
all together and make sure that they
have a theory to tell their jury yeah
and Dr Pearson obviously the police know
more than us but this looks uh this
murder looks more like it's sick and
sadistic than deliberate and personal
but what do you think
second statistic can in fact be
deliberate and personal it depends on
the circumstances I think we need to
look at the information we have
available in this situation we know that
she was found naked that could be
humiliating sadistic if she were alive
to appreciate it but let's look a little
bit further at what the police have said
they've said it's personal crimes that
are personal tend to be things like
stabbing strangulation poison on
occasion uh gunshot wounds are not
considered to be personal that's
typically done from a distance unless
it's by execution style so then we're
left with torture and when you look at
the totality of the facts that we do
know and not including the whole back
evidence that the police are hanging on
to for the purposes of Investigation it
remains to be seen whether this was
really a personal event or a a
deliberate act that was done by people
who didn't know her absolutely well
we'll see what it ends up being and
switching to California where closing
arguments are presented in the trials of
Paul and Ruben Flores as they face
Chargers 26 years after The
Disappearance of Kristen smart the
Father and Son were arrested last year
for the 1996 disappearance of smart a
Cal Poly student who went missing after
an off-campus party in May of that year
Smart's body has never been found Paul
who is charged with her murder was
reportedly the last person seen with her
his father who's charged with accessory
after the fact allegedly helped cover up
Smart's Murder By bearing her in his
backyard and later moving The Remains
the father and son are being tried in
the same courtroom but before two
separate juries jurors have heard months
of testimony from forensic experts
smarts family members and from women who
testified about Paul's previous
inappropriate behavior including an
alleged rape incident closing arguments
in Reuben's case are set for Tuesday
after that jurors will begin
deliberating immediately Paul faces a
possible life sentence his father could
receive up to 3 years in prison
when we come back the jury selection
begins in the Waukesha parade Massacre
trial defendant Daryl Brooks is ordered
to leave the courtroom after multiple
outbursts
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily the
family of Gabby Patito announced his
plans for a new bill that would help
find missing persons the bipartisan bill
was introduced last week with patito's
father calling it quote a huge step
forward the legislation would provide
funding to the National missing persons
and unidentified person system it would
allow the public to access the database
and add to it the bill would also create
incentives to help States report missing
persons and require the Department of
Justice to create updated guidelines for
how to handle a missing person's case
and jury selection begins in Wisconsin
for the Waukesha parade Massacre trial
days after a judge ruled defendant Daryl
Brooks could represent himself Brooks
caused his multiple disruptions in the
courtroom and is even asked to leave
prosecutors Say Brooks drove his vehicle
into the annual Waukesha Christmas
parade last November killing six people
and injuring dozens of others officials
say Brooks did not stop driving even as
victims banged on the hood of his
vehicle motioning for him to stop he now
faces a total of 77 charges related to
the incident including six counts of
homicide by vehicle last week Brooks
made a motion to represent himself
claiming to be a sovereign citizen after
two hearings with multiple outbursts
from Brooks presiding judge Jennifer
Darrow found Brook's competent to
represent himself on Monday jury
selection began as both sides work to
whittle down a 12-person jury with four
alternates from a pool of 340 people
judge Rogue called multiple recesses in
court even before the lunch break as
Brooks argued he doesn't recognize the
name Daryl Brooks and demanded quote
verify proof that he is a United States
citizen
Dr Pearson the judge indicated she could
revoke Brook's right to represent
himself at any time in a trial that's
expected to last for weeks could that
move be likely yes absolutely Brian
frankly I think her decision was uh
ill-advised uh because what we've seen
is somebody who's completely disruptive
and who doesn't recognize the name and
sees himself as a sovereign citizen
whatever that means and so he's hurting
himself and he's hurting the judicial
process and Terry could Brooks not
recognizing his name have anything to do
with him being a sovereign citizen for
those unfamiliar with a case like this
what sort of obstacles could that
provide for the prosecution
absolutely Brian not recognizing his
name could really have something to do
with the fact that he has declared
himself a sovereign Citizen and that
just means that he doesn't recognize the
government or certain governmental
processes unless he consents and so what
we're going to see here is him opting in
and opting out to agree with certain
processes we've already seen he didn't
want to say I understand when the judge
was talking to him about his rights and
about the risks of representing yourself
he's only wanted to say I'm aware of
that I have been informed so I think
it's going to be a very difficult case
for both the prosecution and it's going
to be extremely difficult for the judge
so I think she should have ruled the
other way yeah we'll see how this
continues well thank you for joining us
here on lawn crime daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss Justice in
America
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]